plot the images of points de and F after
dilation centered the origin with a
scale factor of 1/2 so we're going to
center around the origin we want to
scale this thing down by 1/2 so one way
to think about it is the points that
will correspond to points de and F are
going to be 1/2 as far away from the
origin because of our scale factor is
1/2 in either direction so for example
let's let's think about Point D first
Point D is at negative 8 so if we scale
if we have a scale factor of 1/2 what
point D will map to is going to be at
negative 4 on the x-direction and on the
y-direction D is at negative 9 so this
is going to be at negative 4 point 5
half of that so that is going to be
right over there that's where point D is
going to be or the image of point D
after the scaling now let's think about
point E e is 2 more than the origin in
the X direction so it's only going to be
one more once we scale it by 1/2 and
it's 7 more in the Y direction so it's
going to be at 3 and 1/2 7 times one
half is three and 1/2 so we're going to
stick it right over there and then
finally F it's 6 its x-coordinate is 6
more than the origin and its
y-coordinate is 6 less so it's image
after scaling is going to be three more
in the x-direction and 3 less in the
y-direction so it's going to be right
over there so we've plotted the images
of the point so if you were to connect
these points you would essentially have
dilated down d EF with the center at
with width and your center of dilation
would be the origin so let's just write
these coordinates point D and point D
remember what's the point negative 8
negative 9 that's going to map to well
we're going to take half of each of
those so negative 4 and negative 4 point
5 point e maps to well II was it's at 2
7 so it maps to 1 3.5 3.5 and then
finally Point F was it 6 negative 6 so
it maps to 3 it maps to 3 negative 3 so
the important thing to recognize is
the center of our dilation was the
origin so in each dimension in the X
direction or in the Y direction we just
halved the distance from the origin
because the scale factor was 1/2 we got
it right